[Music]
you are have been very successful you
are on multiple shows yet you are still
surprised when other celebrities know
who you are is that true every time
really it never gets old
I was at a party and I saw Amy Schumer
walk in and everybody Amy Schumer and
they started taking pictures so she made
a beeline towards me so I stepped to the
side to the side you know it's so funny
I've had that I've had that same thing
where people whereas someone famous will
like make eye contact with me and then
be like oh and especially earlier on and
then I would immediately always go you
hey whoa I guess we'll be friends now
and then I just see in their eyes busy
alright so you met did you meet Meryl
Streep is it I met her too and she tried
to photobomb me
I mean you are having a good day people
when Meryl Streep jumps behind you in a
pitcher and is like hey and I was like
oh no please get in let me put my arms
around you that's pretty name
of course yeah I was having a moment I
love Meryl Streep thinking I need to get
more attention there's a photograph I'm
not
you